you can say younger so when you were
let's say you know five years old or
older did you both know you wanted to be
writers professionally I maybe that's no
absolutely not so young of a column now
when I didn't know that I wanted to
become a writer until I went to college
I was studying fashion merchandising at
La trade tech and hated my marketing
classes hated the accounting classes and
I took what I thought was going to be an
easy a in fashion writing I studied with
Glenn Jones who is the fashion editor of
the then herald-examiner
she was another she was the first black
woman besides be be more Campbell that I
knew wrote that made a living as a
writer be be more Campbell was an author
and she went to my church and I didn't
understand writing as a career I didn't
know people got paid that some people
don't get paid at all of you anymore but
but when saw something in the work that
I did and she suggested I get an
internship and helps me get an
internship at Women's Wear Daily
I'm not about doing anything else as a
career since there was something very
you know they talked about the power of
the pen and I got a chance to experience
that and what that meant to me how
affecting my work was and the results of
it it was you know like my parents come
from very blue-collar
my mother has a bachelor's degree my
father has an associate's degree but
they're both blue cop they were both
blue-collar worker blue-collar workers
and so you know when I came home one day
and told my parents I am going to become
a journalist my dad was like what is
that and how much does that pay and you
know so that was kind of the the
mentality that I grew up with it was
that you had to have a job that paid and
had to have liked benefits and all those
kinds of things but what I found was
writing was that it it gave me a voice
in the world and it gave me an
opportunity to say something and it also
gave me an opportunity to see things in
ways that I wouldn't ordinarily see like
I could go behind the scenes of stuff
and tell everybody what I saw and so I
think for me writing just writing I came
to writing and it was something that I
didn't even know I had a strengthened
and so I began to develop and hone that
craft but it wasn't something that I set
out to do but now you know like as the
world is changing and everything is now
becoming content you know it's it's
about me finding a way to do the thing
that I love as passionately as I did
when I first started because I don't
like it being called content it's still
writing to me you know something it
means something to me to be a writer
like when blogging came out I was like
no I am a journalist you know I was very
proud of that I was very proud of
calling myself a writer I'm very very
conscientious and proud of being an
artist someone who's transitioned into
something that feels very artistic and
so like content doesn't sound like
anything to me and so content sounds
like stuff you don't really need to pay
for brand new sounds branded content
right so I think that you know as as I
you know as I've come along you know
holding on to that writing that that
thing that says I'm a writer is what
really still because that's what that's
what drew me in was the writing you know
and so they're always you know calls
that you know I should do you know I
should probably be making more
doing more but if it doesn't have
anything to do with writing I don't
really care you know so guaranteed for
you do you remember the first time you
realized I want to be right yeah and and
it was not a quick was not a quick
realization I think I always you look
back in hindsight you're like oh I've
always wanted to be a writer but in in
truth I was I was a huge reader as it
was as a kid yes it was also Indiana yes
it was summer my mom would tell us to go
outside and read but then she would find
me hiding behind the curtains in the
air-conditioning like reading my book or
if I had to go outside I would like
there was this ditch under the highway
overpass where I'd be with my you know
with my book but it never occurred to me
that that I could that I would be a
person who would craft something and
like figure out what these people would
do and then what they would do next and
what they would do next like that seemed
I think super pie-in-the-sky to me like
it it didn't occur to me that that that
was something that I could do I was a
theater major in college and I thought I
was going to direct and a lot of and I'd
look back now and I'm like oh a lot of
the scenes that I directed that were
very successful were scenes I wrote so I
could direct them but of course it was
that combination that made them
successful and and my jobs out of
college I had a pretty by that point I
had a pretty good stage management
background and I parlayed that into
being a production coordinator for
videos and industrials and commercials
in Chicago and then when I made the jump
and came to LA the same kind of thing I
did the logistics for production I think
I always thought oh someday I'm going to
be a director and someday somebody's
going to let me be a director but I
didn't have any sense of what that like
I just thought that you got on a set and
you worked really hard and
you you know organize things and made
the phone calls and you know I was but
there's there's a ladder for that
there's a ladder for helping other
people be creative that you you know you
can go from production this is a
production coordinator to associate
producer to producer and that's that's
something that I did and it wasn't until
I got married and I moved to the middle
of Australia with my husband and while I
oh but I should say that I'm gonna
backtrack a little bit
that as a kid I had you know a bunch of
spiral ring notebooks full of like just
writing so I was a journal or and in
kind of all through my life I've always
been somebody who instinct like I had
right so so there was always that Drive
but I just I didn't I mean I kind of
look back and I'm amazed I'm like how
did I not make this connection
so I'm starting with my husband he was
he was an aerospace engineer at the time
and so it's like we lived in the desert
and like kind of in the middle of
Australia and there's like these
satellite monitoring stations the middle
of a desert I'm like what am I going to
do with myself and so then I started
taking some art classes which was great
and I loved it and I have a little bit
of background in that arena as well and
and then I was diagnosed with cancer in
2003 and in the wake of that it's all a
happy story everything's good now but I
am one of those people who kind of
didn't do the chemotherapy
I like meditated and went to cancer camp
and juice carrots and so at that point I
was like well I don't think I should be
spending you know like eight hours in
the studio with like all the solvents
and the you know the stuff like for
screen printing which was kind of the
main thing that I did and so at that
point I I was kind of like it was it was
just kind of like a weird time I was
kind of physically recovering still
and and you know I had this going on
it's like I'm going to take a writing
class that Gotham Writers Workshop that
online they're associated with zoetrope
and I ended up doing two or three
classes through them and they were great
I highly recommend them so that was kind
of my first official right I think I
think I tested out of English in in
college you know how you you do so I
don't even think I took an English class
in my undergraduate career in college
and I kind of look back I'm like what
was I thinking all I loved to do was
read I didn't even take a literature
class but so I wrote you know so there I
wrote some stories and then one day my
husband's aerospace engineer came home
and he said there's this guy at work
who's quitting to go to film school
he sucks he's terrible at everything
he's like if anybody should go to film
school I should go to film school and
then this kind of like over the course
of a couple of days you know he really
did love movies and he was somebody who
would watch them over and over again
he's like I should go to film school and
then it'd be kind of became this thing
where I'm like well I've always I always
kind of thought oh I'm going to go to
grad school someday and I'm like look
you're going to school I'm going to
school and I'm like what what can I go
to school in like because there's no
grad school for production coordinators
and I and theater didn't seem quite
right after because I'd been working
with film and video all this time I was
like well I wrote these stories for the
Gotham Writers Workshop saying I'm like
I'm gonna get an MFA in writing and then
it seemed like totally I was like yeah
that's what I should do and so I sent my
stories off and I we both got into the
program that before he got into the film
program and I got into the English
Program at Florida State and they had a
good assistantship program like a
teaching you know you could get a TA
ship and so we're like okay that that
seems good and that was so there's a
little bit down the road for me and I
played I had to play a lot of catch-up
because it was an MFA program that was
combined with a ph.d program
so like the very first writing workshop
I took was with a PhD candidate who had
been through the Iowa Writers Workshop
for his MFA and the first thing you have
to do to get into the Iowa Writers
Workshop is I think they give you this
list of 100 books you need to have read
before you even start the program and
you know so I was under ed and under
trend and it's kind of made up for that
since then I've done a lot of I went
from that program and when we moved out
to LA then I use that to get into the
screenwriting program at USC and then I
just kind of as per like my day job
allowed me to pick up some extra classes
and Deb how we did a multi-genre writing
thing at USC as well but anyway so it
took me forever to figure out is is the
answer that question that's how the two
of you met yeah that's how we met I we
weren't there at the so we weren't there
at the same time along we've uh alumna
wait where alumni alumni alumni alumni
Laurel yeah for a female the whole email
isn't a Navarro's alumni know now but
yes we met at a mixer of alums and part
of the afternoon gathering we were
supposed to tell a little bit about
ourselves what we were looking to do and
what we could help someone else in the
group do and I had just started I had
just finished like six weeks of
exhaustive research into Persian culture
for the screenplay adaptation of the
book and barrington or even I think the
instructor mentioned that Barrington
could help anybody with a screenplay and
so I wasn't you know all I what it was
an outline so I thought oh okay so I
made a beeline to her and gave her a
copy of the book and
so that was kind of how we we started
swirling this world it was swirling yeah
so so but it was interesting when
Barrington was talking about her
journaling as it as a young person I did
do a lot of that when I was growing up
and you know because I was such an avid
TV watcher I would find myself
envisioning my self or people that looks
like me into my favorite TV shows and so
my brother and I would sometimes like
write little like guest starring roles
for ourselves in life this would be how
we would see this episode going
you guys were transitioned we did but we
didn't know and like Mort existed yeah
and when you were saying that I was like
you know the fact that I decided to do a
writing course in college for an easy a
was because that was the thing that I
did for fun
but I never imagined doing it as a
profession like I didn't think that was
something you did but I do know like I
would write stories about the kids at
church like I have this I still have it
like my brother asked me about it like
years ago he's like you really should
publish that and it was called all God's
children it was like my soap opera
version of all the kids in church but it
was like and it was like all because
there were all it was hormones were
teenagers it was all these casts of
crazy kids from different walks of life
you know we had kids from Englewood and
Kings Fairfax High and you know all the
school where I wrote rivalries and
things like that and I was the nerdy kid
that all the cool kids talk to and so I
know all their secrets and then of
course I tell my brother all of them cuz
nobody and he was late and so we were I
wrote a little little play thing and I
still have it in my stuff it's like a
one thing that I kept because it's just
hysterical and and I actually won like a
competition in high school for writing
I found that while I was cleaning up
recently so yeah it's funny I never
really thought about it but I think I've
been writing something in some kind of
way my my whole life
you